hello everybody and welcome back to
let's bake cry of fear okay um
Oh tada still making her way down this
town making my way downtown home what
what finally home
oh there I'm so Kay ha ha oh yeah right
no way with the monsters in the
neighborhood are you kidding me wonder
if this is like gonna be the last
episode I don't know baby
it's my bike oh it's my bushes oh look
at the window that looks good I like you
dad
Oh No mom mom where are you mom
oh come on the framerate drops now you
can hear me I didn't even have a save
point
ah you kidding me guys you see this do
you see this
how much [ __ ] is throwing itself at
me ah
that's the worst this is the worst okay
I can't believe it it's gonna screw me
over that hard
oh whatever whatever oh man oh look so
far I don't even have my shotgun this is
at the beginning of the village fine
you know what I wasted a lot of time
just going door-to-door trying to find
places but screw that let me just pick
up the ammo and just get out of here
oh that's annoying
it's beyond annoying there was a guy in
there there I'll pawn you like right
about
you can't see it there you're weird you
go you know they're all right walk it's
lat okay now go up there grab the
assault rifle actually no I'm not even
gonna grab the assault rifle cuz I don't
need the assault rifle because the
assault rifle means I can't I have to
drop my flashlight and screw that you
die
BAM one shot there's the last house
combo I'm not blind
for some strange reason yo and I know
there are monsters in here but what do I
care
oh no monster oh okay just ammo I can
grab it anyway whatever don't matter
alright making my way downtown blah blah
blah I don't know the rest of that song
shut up
you weren't there before just shut up
you
oh you see I know I'm gonna get pwned
cuz I didn't remember to take care of
these ah come on
fine I know god dammit you gotta be guy
damn it ah come on no after you buddy
oh I know he'll forget me if I die if I
don't find a syringe on the way and it's
such baloney
such baloney
oh come on tell me there was a syringe
here if I go back I run into the
douchebags over there I know there was a
syringe somewhere they gave me thousands
off here no just a mo I'm so boned
I'm gonna get in there and I want to die
like instantly
all right I'm gonna go I'm on backtrack
if I die [ __ ] it you know what just
screw it I'm totally boning up the
ending to this game right no I am this
is all supposed to be like a nice clean
sequence and I'm just like Bernard
Werber bitter I'm the happiest if
there's right now let me reload my other
gun shut up okay where could I find a
syringe I know if I backpack enough I'll
just run into one I'll shut up that guy
do not hit me I swear to God it didn't
hit me I won't rip you out from your bed
and tell everyone you wet okay oh yeah
there's a syringe right by this fan oh
thank goodness
okay drop this for now get that oh my
god I'm so bad at games and stuff I'm so
bad just the worst all right whatever
on our way there now we can go into the
house and hopefully my game that break
again that is not fun not fun times okay
mama I'm all coming home
aren't you happy to see me mama
firely home hope mom's okay not gonna
happen bro okay was there anything else
nope okay into the house into the house
he who don't break game
don't break good mom mom mom
oh where are you Dease mom good mom
oh here was this a point oh I could have
saved here and reloaded from here I
wouldn't have known that I'm just glad
I'm here Oh
[Music]
I thought for a second my game went
white again but what haha really hahaha
I'm in a wheelchair now what do hell
happen
I gotta kill myself what was that all
about got a book that it was that one oh
god I cannot control what the hell get
are you kidding me
these are the worst controls ever
I guess if your one-handed trying to oh
nothing in there why does even bother
okay here we go oh gosh the forward
would be nice what the hell holy what is
bad
Haho don't fall off the edge bro just go
holy crap
oh wow I know that Simon had some messed
up stuff going on yes I even have I
don't even have an inventory anymore
well here's hoping I can kill them in
time oh man I tell you these controls
are unwieldy at best
ah nope not today buddy not today
Oh pones you didn't even know you barely
to hit me I don't know if I have enough
ammo to take you
come on buddy pop out pop out what don't
chop got a face full of lead for my own
face view this is some at this is some
allegory to suicide isn't it fighting
for control something like that against
the monster that I have ha I see there
oh yeah oh no hi seven in it
Oh boom hi
going back here I have enough health I
don't think I'm gonna make it might die
and that would be sad
come on I can do it I can do this
ah why do you get automatic guns not
fair not fair man I got one clip left
actually I got to be the one in the yeah
I got two ends he's had a quarter health
I'm at a quarter health as he get better
guns I'm gonna pull this guy ah no come
back here I'm back here come back here
I'm ready for you right in that corner
come on that corner which corner you
come nada
or yeah buddy oh no not about it columns
I can't even see I can't see anything
ah got you maybe that wasn't a good
thing I don't know oh is that the end I
stopped myself from doing it from
committing suicide really but it didn't
only leave me alive it also left two
police officers dead what I kill them
what shot them both this was not
supposed to happen
doctors testified that it was having a
psychosis which means that my punishment
won't be too hard for me to bear what
we're the cops gone the rest of my life
in a mental hospital where nurses and
doctors taking care
they let me finish my book and it has
helped me a lot
I wrote a happy ending just for myself I
feel better now I am more at peace with
myself even though I'm still stuck in
this wheelchair but I accept that now I
can never forgive myself for shooting
those two officers though but I have so
many supportive people around me now so
I think I will be okay
dr. Pernell is mentoring me and is
watching my progress I am lucky to
happen did I have a choice to kill the
Sofie vissa
me every once in a while when the
doctor's letter that is they still think
her visits are too destabilizing for me
Anna it hinders my progress I keep on
telling her how sorry I am for making
her life miserable every time she's here
she just laughs a bit and tells me to
stop being so silly but I can see the
damage I've done to her in her eyes
every time she looks at me she found a
new friend one who is there for her and
treats her right I'm happy for her
though a list of good moments we've had
knowing that they'll never come back I
think this is a good time to close this
book it has changed my life forever
the end
Wow holy crap
whoa hello oh okay oh it's the credits
all right I thought hahaha good job and
whistled rønneberg cannot pronounce
Swedish names for the life of me James
Murr can't prolly Mercante not March
aunt mark aunt oh man oh wow that I'm
still reeling at the fact that this was
a mod this was a mod of a game Geordi
bori Rena boy Rima this was a mod of
half-life 1 1 half-life 1 if you didn't
know was released in 1998 its engine was
nowhere near as good as this this is
heavily modified well done to the max
amazing game I mean it had its bugs but
I'll forgive that for being a free mod I
mean God hello
lass horrid hem who was apparently the
pyro but man that was incredible oh so
very very frightening laughs the less
towards the end but like there was some
moments it I could not believe how
terrified I was and if if I had been
playing this by myself and not for an
audience I never would have finished it
probably but ah man I can't praise it
enough like to thank the people who made
it for just doing it for free I would
have paid 10 bucks for that game I would
have paid more I would have played up to
20 bucks for that game easy no doubt
about it like I would have totally
supported them if they wanted to do that
and all of this was done by what five
people was it one two three four five
six different people yeah it is six
people on some extra people who did um
other stuff okay
small team all for free I can't believe
it that's amazing everyone should go out
and try this mod or if there's like a
support page or a donate page I don't
know they deserve it they deserve all of
that I still don't know where the police
came in like I don't know where had a
choice to kill him or no I never even
saw them in the game so is that part of
the co-op campaign I have no idea but
anyway uh it's just totally confusing
because I figured out that the world
wasn't real early on obviously and that
it was all in Simon's head news result
of the accident but still that was an
amazingly oh good good they have plenty
of donators ups I'm glad to see that
look at all them thank you every one of
those guys every one of those guys is
great I may even go back and donate
myself whenever I get a chance here
because dr. Cola and dr. pepper really
really frisky noodle
oh you guys are clever clever rayve bot
alright man but yeah and thank you guys
for watching this has been a long let's
play I did not expect a mod to take
however many up since I don't even know
34 35 episodes man just an incredible
game incredible incredible game God
everyone should try that everyone should
get the pants scared off them it should
be easier now that you've seen me get
the pants scared off me
PewDiePie even donated good for him
alright and man thanks for playing thank
you from making the game sir
I'm just waiting now see if there's
anything at the end of the credits play
thanks again all you guys these are like
the this is the first ending that I'll
get on my new channel so difficulty
chosen easy I did not choose easy
I saw ending six really that's ending 6
how many endings were there I got an F
yeah I took an overall almost 20,000
damage my accuracy was 11%
I took 68 hours no I didn't I did not
take 68 hours to play this game haha and
he was killed by melee 152 I think that
might be a little off maybe a little off
but anyway I think the statistics are a
little wonky there but either way I
don't care that I got an F and I did not
choose easy if you go back I chose
medium because I don't choose easy
violin whoa how was it amazing game so
Missy unlocked book page 5 oh I can
actually unlock pages of book let me go
see unlockables all but is still
recording Oh
came for us maybe huh now came from I
hope it's still recording if it is thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next part
bye bye earth the next game rather fight